if you had to sum up your drag race
experience and a couple words what would
you say I would say it was it was a
bumpy ride it was a smooth ride but it
was the ride of my life
whoo I feel like you made me rehearse
that no no you're just that quick it's
such a smooth talker Arielle Versace you
are my baby tonight and you always will
be
yeah sashay away
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you hope The fans walk away um I
just hope that they think I'm like
relatable kids you know I just like to
put forth like a positive energy I like
to have fun I always say that if you're
not having fun and drag why are you
doing it it's always super important to
always be professional but have fun so I
just want the fans to really enjoy the
looks the personality because once I
start traveling around I just want to
make friends of everyone party I'm a
little party you know she's just a
Jersey girl she's ready to turn off yeah
speaking of friends did you make any
friends for life out of this cast um I
had only known her a little bit prior to
the show but me and soju or now so like
close she's like one of my like closest
friends we talked on the phone like
literally every day she's just she's so
awesome and I think that's was a really
rewarding experience to come out of the
show to have somebody that like whether
the same thing as you but I don't know
we're just so close we share so many
things I'd love her Stan soju and me yes
a more importantly me
[Music]